Kirby might not carry quite the same
level of prestige as Nintendo's most
famous platforming mascot but you'd be
hard-pressed to find a reason why in
Kirby triple deluxe it's as inventive as
platformers come unashamedly making use
of just about every piece of 3d trickery
around to craft some wildly unique
colorful and thoroughly masterful levels
more impressive is how triple deluxe
make such trickery seem absolutely
effortless there are some very clever
moments here for they never come at the
expense of a solid piece of platforming
it helps that you're introduced to
triple deluxe is 3d charms gradually
before having to deal with enemies
flying in from the background to the
foreground cannons that shoot you deep
into the back of a level and things that
squashy right up against the screen
new ideas and challenges fly in thick
and fast but so well implemented that
they rarely overwhelm you the boss
battles are particularly brilliant
making use of the games 3d depths
produced some thoroughly enjoyable
encounters this is one of the few 3ds
games that really makes use of the
handheld 3d screen you can play with the
3d off with shadows and blurring helping
to define what isn't and isn't in the
foreground but having the 3d on helps
massively in navigating the intricate
levels numerous puzzles and a selection
of classic kirby power-ups are extremely
well done and the level of detail that's
gone into each and every one is
impressive certain levels let you
unleash a neon blast of Kirby's rainbow
colored hypernova ability which lets him
vacuum up nigh on everything that's on
screen and shift around large objects
that would otherwise be a moveable to
solve puzzles none of the puzzles are
especially challenging such as the
aesthetic charms on show as you solve
them it's hard to be disappointed
indeed triple Deluxe's levels feature
some of the prettiest visuals on the 3ds
with a striking color palette to gawk at
and the always cute Kirby and his vast
array of adorable facial expressions to
fall in love with it's a gorgeous game
but its levels are also superbly
balanced and expertly crafted while
being as imaginative as anything to come
from the platforming benchmark that is
the Mario series the game is stuffed
with content - there are secrets to be
found on every level stars to collect
and an amusing rhythm based minigame and
multiplayer fighting games to dig into
you even have the option of going back
and playing the game again as the mallet
smashing king DD complete with remix
levels and bosses and it's a tempting
proposition when the platforming is this
good Kirby triple deluxe is an absolute
diamond of a game and cements Kirby's
place is nothing less than a bonafide
platforming superstar
you